so seit drei wochen haben jetzt schon
deutschlands schulen geschlossen es wird
ihnen aufgefallen sein und nach alldem
homeschooling nach dem unterrichten der
eigenen kinder stellen sich viele eltern
die selben fragen erstens warum haben
wir damals nicht verhütet zweiten
ehrlich warum haben wir nicht verhütet
und drittens wie zum teufel soll man die
nerven kleinen branchen jetzt noch
wochen lang beschäftigen
in china macht es vor taekwondo kuss im
livestream entspannen beim puzzeln oder
als schulaufgabe das virus basteln
kohlkopf mit stäbchen und blaubeer dafür
gibt es bei uns maximal 3 - wenn ein
deutsches kind ein corona virus
nachbilden soll dann was
selbstverständlich einen mett igel ist
ja klar
pädagogisch sinnvoll und lecker so liebe
eltern wer weiß wann unsere schulen
wieder aufmachen das weiß ehrlicherweise
keiner
bis es soweit ist müssen sie aber ihren
kindern bitte zu hause alles bieten was
die sonst in der schule erleben alles
das heißt geben sie ihrem sohn nicht nur
taschengeld sondern klauen sie ist eben
auch direkt wieder direkt danach das
kennt er vom schulhof und für ein
realistisches schul feeling bitte das
cyber mobbing nicht vergessen
ganz wichtig ganz wichtig aber das
wichtigste auf keinen fall mehr ihre
toilette putzen damit es riecht wie auf
dem schulklo und natürlich in der großen
pause schon mit dem junior eine quarzen
ja schule feeling in sachen schule
lautet die gute nachricht aber die
prüfungen finden statt in diesem jahr
aber natürlich föderalismus teil heißt
jedes bundesland macht anders wie immer
in manchen kriegen die abiturienten
jetzt deutlich mehr zeit zur
vorbereitung wochen mehr in rheinland
pfalz und hessen finden die prüfungen
wie geplant statt eine gewagte
entscheidung aber der hessische
kultusminister erklärt es den schülern
wirklich sehr einfühlsam folgen sie den
anweisungen der aufsicht führende
lehrkräfte versammeln sie sich nicht auf
dem schulhof gehen sie zu ihrem platz
sie werden weit genug von ihren
kameraden in den kameraden entfernt
sitzen
ich hoffe die kameradinnen und kameraden
haben sich das aufgeschrieben crazy
vorschlag meinerseits wir versuchen es
in diesen außergewöhnlichen zeiten
einfach doch mal mit einem bundesweit
einheitlichen und vergleichbaren abitur
warum nicht es klingt verrückt aber
warum nicht auch das geht doch
heutzutage problemlos im internet ja
einfach bei youtube mit studienrat ag
dietmar wischmeyer das corona youtube
notabitur mit dietmar wischmeyer soja
kleid quarantäne leute jetzt wird es
ernst er drei minuten fürs corona note
aa wie das heißt ihr müsst euch leider
mal drei minuten am stück konzentrieren
und denkt dran
ich sehe was ihr macht nichts denn
gefährlich die hand aus der hose
also los geht's mit mathe textaufgabe
wenn alle 80 millionen deutsche 2 meter
abstand voneinander halten wie groß ist
an deutschland genauso groß wie jetzt
b so groß wie 1937 oder c nur noch so
groß wie damals bevor wir uns die zone
gekauft haben ankreuzen
weiter gehts biologie
es gibt zwei kriege kamele einhellige
und bernd haake frage wie wir kamele
sind das insgesamt
das war eine harte nuss und weil ich
weiß dass eure aufmerksamkeit spanne für
genau 30 sekunden reicht immer was
lustig ist seit spannung
der leguan hat gefurzt weitergeht dass
politik wer regiert die bundesrepublik
das robert koch institut
b das marianne koch institut c
robert habeck oder de das maggi
kochstudio war zu einfach
religion wie kann ich mit gott kontakt
aufnehmen
auf seiner facebook seite indem ich das
wort zum sonntag leike oder gott ist bei
amazon prime mit drin und zum schluss
das wichtigste aber von allen sachkunde
was macht dieser mann windrad setzlinge
pflanzen b den spargel zurück in die
erde drücken oder c den spargel
streicheln damit der hard und groß wird
so das war es auch schon
herzlichen glückwunsch zur
hochschulreife und denkt dran nächste
woche machen wir hier das abitur nur für
berliner schüler zur vorbereitung
empfehle ich euch dieses buch kevin hat
drei kekse rechne mit einer hand ich
glaube an euch
was wie und unter aller sobald wir eine
millionen abonnenten liebe liebe liebe
fans ich würde mich so was schon freuen
wenn ihr ein abo dallas braucht jung
er würde den gern als so was von
glücklich machen